[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et si je vous offrait un système qui
pourrait vous permettre de dessiner sur
n'importe quel mur sur n'importe quelle
surface sans avoir besoin de nettoyer
après et si je vous fournissez un mur de
plus de 6000 pieds carrés sur lequel
vous pourriez vous exprimer librement
et bien je vous annonce aujourd'hui que
ce projet là existe je les fais le 16
juin dernier sur la façade ouest du
grand théâtre une façade environ 6000
pieds carrés
j'étais avec une gang de jeunes et
d'artistes professionnels pensent ans on
a fait des dessins géants pendant
environ 1h30 de temps devant plus de 200
personnes
donc comment nina locke comment on en
est arrivé là et bien que tu te crois
qu'ils peuvent
comment on en est arrivé là et bien moi
la première fois où j'ai eu cette idée
là de faire du geste du graffiti une
performance numérique c'est ya plusieurs
années à l'époque je commençais à
m'intéresser à la projection vidéo
architectural et je sortais avec une
fille qui s intéresser aux graffitis
alors j'ai eu l'idée de mixer les deux
phares du graffiti architectural grâce
aux technologies de projection vidéo
c'est resté sous forme ce deuil pendant
plusieurs années jusqu'à l'automne
dernier j'étais en réunion avec
quelques-uns de mes collaborateurs de ma
jeune entreprise interférences art et
technologie
on est tombé sur un appel d'offres de
l'entente de développement culturel
entre le ministère la culture et la
ville de québec s'appelait graffitis et
tags numérique et aux graffitis tags
virtuel exclusivement gardons donc ce
qu'est la ville recherché avec ce projet
là c'était d'amener des jeunes à
s'intéresser à leur patrimoine
architectural à partir d'un projet
d'arts numériques
donc mon idée de fusionner graffiti et
architecture tombe exactement dans ce
qu'ils cherchaient j'avais donc les
bonnes bases pour leur proposer un super
projet il y avait un petit problème
cependant c'est qu'on a vu l'appel
d'offres un peu tard il
c'est à peine une semaine pour déposer
sauf que je me suis vite rendu compte
que c'était pas vraiment un problème
parce qu'à travers mes années
d'expérience dans le domaine des arts et
des technologies j'ai su développer un
réseau d'artistes d'artisans
professionnels et passionnés dont il
soit fait que ça me plaît à peine une
journée montrent une équipe solide
ensuite le lendemain on s'est rencontrés
on a développé un super projet on aurait
dit l'appel d'offres et on a eu le
financement une fois qu'on use
financement il faut lui réalisé le
projet et ça c'était tout un défi pour
vous donner une idée du début du projet
à la réception du financement jusqu'à
l'événement final le 16 juin sur le
grand théâtre
il s'est écoulé environ cinq mois dans
ces cinq mots l'oeil a fallu inventer le
système le programme et le fabriquer
pour m'aider dans cette tâche
j'ai fait appel à alexandre qu'ici qui
est un programmeur qui a beaucoup
d'expérience en projet artistique
ensuite il faut lui faire une recherche
approfondie sur le patrimoine de la
ville de québec pour m'aider dans cette
tâche
j'ai fait appel à dominique zilina qui
est une muséologue et spécialiste en
numérique
ensuite il faut lui développé tout
l'aspect médiation culturelle avec les
jeunes pour cette partie j'ai fait appel
à nathalie côté qui est une murale est
passionné ce graffiti puisqu'elle fait
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de projets
avec des jeunes pour nous a aidé à
recruter les jeunes
on ne travaille avec l'école joseph
françois perrault au centre-ville de
québec et finalement il faut lui
organiser l'événement à grand
déploiement avec tout ce que ça implique
de logistique technique et de gestion de
ressources humaines et pour m'aider j'ai
fait appel à marie lise gagnon qui est
une jeune lectrice de production de
québec
donc le premier élément qui peut lui
faire c'est développer le système
numérique
j'ai ici avec moi la fameuse canne est
numérique que j'ai développé moi même
dans mon atelier
donc comment ça fonctionne c'est que si
on une led infrarouges qui est captée
par une caméra ici puis l'ordinateur
quatre images de caméra et peut analyser
il est capable de positionner la can et
la canette dans l'espace c'est d'onyx y
leur sont envoyées à un ordinateur qui
fait ce dessin vous m'excuserez je vous
tournez le dos pendant un instant pour
la démonstration
donc comme vous pouvez voir mon curseur
suis mon mouvement dans l'espace
on espère savoir bien marché ce qui me
permet de pouvoir faire un graffiti sur
un mur distincts avec des mouvements
dans les airs ici
donc ici j'ai utilisé le projecteur
vidéo de tedx québec alors que le 16
juin dernier c'était le mur du gras
théâtre quelque chose de super important
que je vous ai à propos de ce projet là
c'est que l'ensemble développement
logiciel et de la canette est sous
licence libre de droit ça ça veut dire
que n'importe qui ici dans la salle qui
en avait la volonté peut construire son
système de graffitis numérique à la
maison parce que l'ensemble du code puis
l'ensemble des schémas de la canette
sont disponibles gratuitement sur
internet
c'est super important pour interférence
de développer des projets comme ça parce
que nous on croit que l'art c'est fait
pour être partagé de développer des
projets libres de droit ça nous assure
que le plus grand nombre possible l'eau
qui ont accès à ces outils là notre
élément super important du projet
c'était tout l'aspect de recherches
patrimoniales passe faut pas oublier que
c'était le cas du projet d'amener des
jeunes à mieux connaître leur patrimoine
architectural pour leur montrer que
l'archer le patrimoine c'est pas juste
des vieilles bâtisses en fait le
patrimoine c'est vous c'est moi c'est
nous qui tous ensemble de par notre
appartenance historique et symbolique à
certains édifices c'est ça qui crée le
patrimoine
donc après plusieurs heures de
recherches
dominique gélinotte est arrivé avec un
choix de 23h10 fils patrimoniaux c'est
et 23 êtes ici cela qu'ils ont constitué
la base de la création de graffitis
numérique qu'on a fait avec les jeunes
donc les ateliers quand je traverse des
projets l'eau à nathalie elle était
super emballé tout de suite à la suite
vu le potentiel du dispositif la
première chose qui m a demandé si on
allait pouvoir projeter sur le complexe
jouer à partir de la basse ville j'ai
dit oui nathalie c'est techniquement
possible mais j ai aussi dit qu'on
n'aurait pas les moyens pour cette année
donc c'est ça notre nathalie s'est
occupé de l'ensemble des ateliers que
les jeunes et de l'ensemble la direction
artistique du projet durant les ateliers
en vue de la théorie sur le patrimoine
la théorie sur le graffiti
on a fait de la pratique de graffitis
réel avec la vraie peinture de l'encré à
l'extérieur et ensuite on a fait de la
pratique à l'intérieur avec
le projecteur vidéo donc des graffitis
avec de la lumière d'où vient le nom du
projet ancré lumière
ensuite pour terminer ces ateliers l'on
ne finit avec une fin de semaine intense
et de création on est au laboratoire des
nouvelles technologies de l'image sont
et de la scène à l'université laval
puisqu'on avait accès à un plus grand
projecteur vidéo et un plus grand mur
qui pendant deux jours de temps il y
avait un atelier que les jeunes qui crée
le spectacle pendant qu'alexandre et moi
on a juste et puis on augmentait les
capacités du logiciel qu'à chaque fois
qu'on va acheter quelque chose on leur
ajoute t on mettre à jour ses
ordinateurs natale utiliser ces nouveaux
ajouts là pour continuer dans création
c'était une super belle dynamique de
création tout au long de ce fin de
semaine l'a ensuite le 16 juin arrive
côté technique c'est ecc6 projecteur
vidéo de 20000 humaine un système de
sont performants et une mise en lumière
complète du site
la technique était prêt le public est au
rendez-vous les dj était prêt nous
autres avec les jeunes artistes on était
prêts donc le spectacle a commencé je
vous ai dit au début de ma présentation
que celle avait duré environ une heure
trente est bien pour nous dans
l'excitation du moment pendant le stress
de le faire pendant l'accomplissement nu
l'impression que ça dure et je peux 15
20 minutes gros maximum puis après la
performance les jeunes étaient super
fier étaient super contents de ce qu'ils
avaient accompli
la première chose qui nous ont dit c'est
savoir si on leur faisait le lendemain
soir sauf que malheureusement le projet
ancré lumière était bel et bien terminé
cependant le dispositif de graffitis
numérique lui existe encore
puis c'est une des missions que je me
donne avec interférences de l'amener
plus loin de voir qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire avec ce système là parce que c'est
un système qui répond vraiment bien aux
deux missions principales
d'interférences c'est à dire la
production et la demande
la démocratisation d'oeuvre qui intègre
les arts et la technologie
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]